Community rallies behind the golden
knights as they prepare for the Stanley
Cup Playoffs the team also does its part
to give back to Loyal fans 8 news now
reporter Mary Jane beliesa shares how
the team recognizes local organizations
and raises Awareness on some pretty
important topics
it's a blessing because you know
non-profits rely on donations
sponsorships and volunteer help so to be
able to get you know a sizable donation
like that you know really allows us to
be able to do more events more
programming Chris Devon the executive
director of the Henderson Equality
Center is grateful for the team's
Outreach a twenty thousand dollar
donation from The Pride night event will
help their clients right now we're
looking at a lot of businesses that are
out there that you know are taking a
step back because they're worried about
the political realm of what's Happening
you know so with the NHL you know
staying in the Forefront you know we
need more businesses to follow Linda
Perez agrees as the CEO of Shadetree
which provides a safe haven for women
and children the knights not only made a
hefty donation for women's history month
but shared how people can get involved I
wish them all the best
um in the in the in the upcoming games
it's going to be so exciting but I also
want to share yeah I'm a Survivor of
domestic violence and this work is so
important to us and our fam families in
the community and the Vegas golden
knights just by highlighting us just by
bringing awareness to what the shade
tree does has really helped us helping
kids is also a top priority Peter Guzman
president of the Latin Chamber of
Commerce says the team donates to a
scholarship that helped kids go to
school they've done an amazing job not
only with the Latin chamber but with the
Hispanic community and that's been from
day one like Bill Foley personally
wanted this to happen under Kerry's
leadership they have been very sincere
about it came to Latin chamber said hey
we want Hispanics to know that hockey is
their sport as well
other organs
Oregon Express their support towards the
golden knights and their efforts the
public Education Foundation says quote
about 3 000 Clark County School District
teachers and their students have
received free school supplies thanks to
a partnership between the public
education foundation and the Vegas
golden knights Foundation our teachers
appreciate the support
in fact the entire city is behind the
knights right we want to give you a
chance to show the team that you've got
Spirit you can send pictures and videos
maybe of your family your dog whatever
even your house if you've got it all
decked out Knights gear we'd love to see
it picks pix at 8newsnow.com is the
email address to send those pictures or
videos and we'd love to share your
team's spirit with our city